new york governor andrew cuomo the
supposed hero of the coveted 19 pandemic
resigns from office joe biden makes some
incredibly tone-deaf comments about it
and democrats everywhere push mass
mandates again i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben will get to all the news and there's
a lot of news in just one moment first
your reminder if you're like me and
you're always on the lookout for new
things today is your lucky day because
black rifle coffee long time friends of
the show are introducing a new ready to
drink canned coffee 300. now honestly i
couldn't be more into this considering
that i have had less sleep in the last
month than i think any time the rest of
my life so that means that now is a
perfect time for coffee products from my
friends over at black rifle coffee black
rifle coffee company is a veteran-owned
coffee company serving premium coffee to
people who love america veteran ceo and
founder evan hafer spent over seven
years on the ground overseas with u.s
special forces and as a cia contractor i
haven't even modified his gun trucks
during the invasion of iraq to grind
coffee anywhere giving back to those who
serve is at the core of brcc's culture
in 2020 brc donated more than six
million cups of coffee to deployed
soldiers law enforcement medical workers
through their signature buy a bag give a
bag initiative and right now brcc is
introducing a new line of ready to drink
canned coffee the new 15-ounce comes
with 300 milligrams of caffeine per can
100 colombian coffee high quality
ingredients and an energizing blend of
mct oil and amino acids to fuel your
energy and focus forever mission lies
ahead and of course it comes in a couple
of delicious flavors caramel vanilla and
rich mocha whether you're on a big hunt
or a cross-country road trip 300 gives
you a convenient way to enjoy premium
coffee when you don't have the time or
equipment to make your own brew head on
over to blackriflecoffee.com shapiro use
code shapiro to get the new ready to
drink 300 and save 20 off your first
order that is blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro code shapiro alright well there
is a man who needs a drink that man's
name andrew cuomo he is no longer going
to be governor of new york he's giving
himself 14 days to slow the spread
apparently he is not going to resign for
another two weeks but he says he is
leaving right as of now
he said on tuesday he will resign
relinquishing under extraordinary
pressure his decade long grip on power
heading off a potential impeachment by
new york's democratic-led legislature a
week after the release of a report by
the state agency found that he had
sexually harassed 11 women here is what
it sounded like when andrew cuomo
announced his resignation
i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing
for you
because as we say it's not about me
it's about we oh my god it's not about
me it's about we and by we he means your
breasts
honestly the guy's gonna have to step
down from office after killing every old
person in the state of new york and then
covering it up because he allegedly
groped a woman's breasts that's that's
that's really what this is about like
that's like that's a bad thing to do but
it seems like you know killing every
elderly person in new york and then
covering it up is a much worse thing to
do and this is the thing that's so
amazing the they're really only they're
really two reasons why cuomo is going
down here one is because cuomo is an
inconvenient figure for democrats at
this time he's inconvenient because he
actually did an unbelievably crappy job
over the course of the last year during
the pandemic new york by all available
statistics still has the second highest
death per million rate in the nation
slightly after new jersey right now new
york has the fourth highest unemployment
rates in america
okay so those are not good stats from
the governor of new york who's
championed as this wonderful wonderful
dude last year and so democrats had a
choice they could either rethink how
they approached the pandemic and throw
cuomo under the bus on that score or
they could find another reason to throw
him under the bus and conveniently
enough earlier this year out came these
allegations that he had been grabbing
people's asses and that was a perfect
excuse to go after andrew cuomo beyond
that andrew cuomo has no allies because
here's the thing the media spent a year
treating andrew cuomo like he was some
sort of beloved figure in new york
people hate andrew cuomo in new york i'm
talking about the political class the
political class in new york they despise
andrew cuomo and there's a reason that
bill de blasio hates him there's a
reason that the entire new york state
legislature hates andrew cuomo he is a
jerk everybody who's in a position of
power to save him it was like batman at
the end of batman begins right they're
not going to kill him but they also
don't have to save him except this time
they actually were going to kill him and
so he had to step back and step down and
even now he's still making it about
himself even as he steps down he can't
just apologize he has to just say you
know it's about it's not i'm not doing
this for me i'm doing this for we and
then he continues by saying that he
apologizes for offending the women at no
point does he ever say he did anything
wrong by the way
see the real reason that he's resigning
here is because you watch within four
years they're going to be talking about
him coming back in fact as we'll see
members of the media are already talking
about him coming back and he's not even
gone yet like give us a little time to
miss him gang but here is andrew cuomo
apologizing for women being offended
the most serious allegations made
against me
had no credible factual basis in the
report
and there is a difference
between alleged improper conduct
and concluding sexual harassment
now don't get me wrong
this is not to say that there are not 11
women who i truly offended
there are
and for that i deeply deeply apologize
okay so his line here is that he is very
very sorry that somebody was offended
but also he didn't do anything wrong he
just sort of breached some etiquette by
allegedly grabbing women and kissing
them on the lips and touching them in
weird ways and asking them weird
questions and all the rest and this was
his line throughout the throughout the
presser right he said my sense of humor
can offend people sometimes
he just you know it's it's really on
them because they get offended it's
really not on andrew cuomo no point here
does he actually take full blame for
anything that he has allegedly done
right which is why he's
he's leaving the door opens he here's
the thing if he once it became clear he
was going to be impeached he had to
resign because if he had been impeached
he could never come back but if he
resigned he could theoretically come
back
four years from now saying well you know
those allegations really never panned
out and i stepped down because it was
necessary for me to step down at the
time but now that we know that those
things didn't pan out well i think maybe
i'll come back you this is what happened
with for example senator al franken
right when al franken stepped down as
senator from minnesota over allegations
of grasping women's behinds and rope
lines
he he's now talked about coming back
pretty openly i think cuomo is trying to
leave the door open for that here is
andrew cuomo then going on to try and
defend his legacy right so even as he's
leaving he's defending his garbage
legacy
we made new york state the progressive
capital of the nation
no other state government accomplished
more to help people and that is what
it's all about
just think about what we did we passed
marriage equality creating a new civil
right
legalized love for the lgbtq community
and we generated a force for change that
swept the nation
um
really that's it so your legacy is gay
marriage and killing all the olds
and
lots of people leaving the states like
so many people leaving the state that
you couldn't even raise taxes anymore
because you were afraid that if you
raised taxes anymore every wealthy
person in the state of new york was
going to leave again
what he's really doing here is he's just
attempting to preserve a future
political lifeline so don't take this
the way the democrats are taking this is
look how wonderful we are we were going
to stop him because we have principles
and andrew cuomo resigned because andrew
cuomo no none of you people have
principles because you're all
politicians so shut up okay we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk for a second about your
safety and security at home so you may
have noticed that we are traveling but i
can still keep an eye on my home
anywhere i am on planet earth because i
have ring devices all over my house
there are a thousand reasons why
protecting your home matters to you and
there are many reasons why protecting my
home it matters to me if somebody stops
by something is going on outdoors around
the home ring will let me know it's
peace of mind anytime knowing our home
is protected protect your home with ring
alarm ring alarm is a powerful
affordable home security system you can
easily install it yourself and it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer go to
ring.com
ben it's the perfect way to start that
ring experience keep an eye on every
corner of your house at the indoor and
outdoor cam see what's happening right
from your phone every time i go out of
town and my kids are in town i keep an
eye on them by using ring alarm making
sure i know that they are safe protect
your home anytime from anywhere with
ring alarm go to ring.com
for a special offer on ring alarm
security kit today you can build a
system right for your home have it up
and running in just minutes that is
ringit.com once more ring.com
ben all right just as the proof that
andrew cuomo is not actually apologetic
about any of this let's recall that
before andrew cuomo actually resigned
his personal lawyer a woman named rita
glavin gave a 42-minute monologue in
which she just tore into everybody who
had made an allegation about andrew
cuomo so for example cuomo's attorney
trashed two accusers specifically one
was named brittany camiso she of course
is the woman who alleged that andrew
cuomo had rubbed her butt and that he
had then called her into his office and
stuck his hand up her shirt and lindsey
boylan who had suggested that he had
kissed her on the lips and then he had
made inappropriate comments cuomo's
attorney just trashed them right before
he got up and resigned so this is not
about andrew cuomo actually admitting
fault it's precisely the opposite right
he wants to leave on his own terms
before his impeachment sort of seals his
record into into stone
there was also testimony by several
evidence by several witnesses
about potential motives and what was
going on with miss miss camiso
in late 2020 and early 2021
and concerns she had about her
job that she had been turned down for a
raise
and concerns that there was a
possibility
that because her work hours might change
she could be transferred you see miss
boylan had ran in a primary against
congressman jerry nadler
and
in march of 2020 when coveted started
the governor issued an executive order
which
narrowed the time frame for people to
get petitions they could get on the
ballot
miss boylan was very unhappy about this
and felt that
that had been directed at her so why not
stay and fight it out
really i mean you've got your lawyer out
there making a 40-minute presentation
about why all the accusers are not
credible why not stand fight it out and
the answer of course is that cuomo had
alienated so many people inside the
democratic party that it didn't matter
what evidence he provided on the other
side he was going to be impeached
i mean cuomo's attorney basically
acknowledged this and she said the
investigators brought their own bias i
mean she's going after attorney general
leticia james here pointing out that
leticia james has her eye on the
governor seat which of course is true
the two investigators
that were charged with this report
certainly and it comes through when you
read it
they brought their own biases
mr kim had pursued and supervised
criminal investigations against the
governor for years at that office and he
actually personally interviewed him
personally interviewed governor cuomo
one of the criminal investigations
and with respect to ms clark
as an attorney her practice is focused
on bringing sexual harassment and
discrimination lawsuits on behalf of
employees
okay by the way no one is ever no one
ever really goes away right no one ever
really dies when it comes to politics
unless you're dead and even then maybe
not
it's like the last jedi nobody ever
really goes away but
it's not just andrew who's not going to
go away apparently chris is going to
stick around too you know chris is still
advising him from cnn there's a report
in the washington post that mentions
buried in paragraph 11 that chris cuomo
is still advising his brother despite
the fact that basically he's been
suspended from duty for advising his
brother now the angle that democrats are
taking with regard to cuomo leaving are
it's a really strange angle normally
when somebody leaves you don't celebrate
them you don't talk about what a
wonderful job they did latisha james
just put out a 168-page report about
what a terrible person andrew cuomo is
and then she put out a statement saying
i thank governor cuomo for his
contributions to our state
i mean like what
joe biden did the same thing by the way
he started off by saying he respected
cuomo's decision and then he had to be
told what cuomo's decision was and also
who andrew cuomo was because obviously
the president of the united states is no
longer with us unfortunately but as we
say no one ever really dies here is joe
biden saying that he respects andrew
cuomo's decision
what is your reaction to governor
cuomo's
his announcement that he's stepping down
you called on him to resign did you
think he would
i respect the governor's decision and uh
i i respected sushi maine
okay but the best comment here from joe
biden is the most telling comment and
that is when biden feels the necessity
to praise cuomo again understand
democrats really wanted to cap cuomo
here for a couple of reasons one is that
he's a jerk but the other is that cuomo
was a really inconvenient figure for
them they made a hero out of the guy and
he was awful on kovid i cannot express
this enough andrew cuomo had a coveted
policy by which he shipped covet
positive elderly patients back into
nursing homes who then went on to infect
everybody in the nursing homes and then
when these people got so sick they had
to be shipped to the hospitals he
promptly had his death count not count
them as nursing home patients instead
they were counted as people who died
outside nursing homes
that was like somewhere between nine and
eleven thousand elderly people who were
counted as non-nursing home patients
when they were active
when they were actually nursing home
patients when they got the disease and
they were shipped out like a day before
they died to the local hospital
like he was a bleep show on this stuff
and he was treated as this sort of
magical figure by the media and the
democrats can't let this go because
here's the thing cuomo's model which
failed and it did it failed cuomo's
model is still the model democrats are
pursuing today
democrats like to purport that they have
an answer to covet they do not have an
answer to covet because no one has an
excellent answer to covet the only
answer to covet so far as anyone is
aware at this point is the vaccine
that's it the masks are not a long term
or even medium term or maybe even short
romance or when it comes to the delta
variant
there are no other answers you're not
going to lock down forever you can't do
that you're not going to tell people
they can't go out of their houses
forever you can't do that people are not
up for that anymore and so if they
cannot dissociate from andrew cuomo's
actual record on covet they'll
dissociate from andrew cuomo on other
grounds that is what we were seeing
right here and that brought joe biden to
this bizarre impasse where he had to
talk about what a wonderful person and
governor andrew cuomo was and then
express that that's why his personal
behavior was sad
sad
like did it just happen to him sad is
when like your puppy gets run over by a
car sad is not when the governor of the
state of new york decides that he is
going to grab some boob of a subordinate
that's not sad that's perverse
hey here's joe biden making a rather
large boo-boo
how would you assess
his ten and a half years
as governor of the state
in terms of his personal behavior or
what he's done as a governor
i thought he's done a hell of a job
but he's done a hell of a job
and uh
i mean both on everything from
access to voting to infrastructure the
whole range of things
that's why it's so sad that's it's so
sad it's so sick by the way he didn't do
a hell of a job he did a crappy job
that's why all the other new york
legislators are looking forward to
dumping his body in a shallow grave in
iowa politically speaking we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact if you've
got a medical problem you need to go get
it solved sitting around waiting for it
to go away that is not going to help
particularly if it's a life-changing
problem like erectile dysfunction with
roman you can get quick discreet easy
care from the privacy of your own home
roman ready means confidence the
confidence you know that you can rise to
the occasion in the moment a u.s
licensed healthcare professional will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan if medication is appropriate it
ships you free with two-day shipping the
whole process is straightforward
convenient and discreet getting started
is super simple just go to getroman.com
ben complete an online visit today take
care of your ed without leaving your
home complete that online visit today
connect with the us licensed healthcare
professional and get the problem taken
care of head on over to getroman.com ben
today if you're prescribed to get 50 off
your first month of ed treatment make
sure you're ready to have confidence and
control this summer roman ready again
medical problems these are not things
that just go away on their own even if
they seem to be embarrassing and
getroman.com ben can make it not
embarrassing and also can help you take
care of the problem
getroman.com ben to get 50 off your
first month of ed treatment if you are
prescribed okay so
biden makes that amazing statement where
he says that cuomo's done an amazing job
and that's why his behavior is sad
caitlyn collins took her credit from cnn
did a bit of actual journalism not
journalism actual journalism and she
followed up with biden and she said um
you know you said he did an amazing job
but um he did sexually harass half the
women he ever met in the office
can you really say that he has done a
quote hell of a job if he's accused of
sexually harassing him
the question is did he do a good job on
infrastructure that was the question
he did
as a governor no the question was
correct me if i'm wrong
no i'm not i was asked a specific
question okay so no no you can't
separate the two but you can separate
the two weird because we were told when
trump was president you definitely could
not separate the two remember this was
joe biden's pitch for the presidency is
that his character made him fit for the
presidency unlike that evil dullard
donald trump who is so terrible to women
also we were supposed to ignore the
terror read allegations because joe
biden is obviously a wonderful wonderful
person jen saki then tried to explain
her way out of this little conundrum she
tweeted out president responded to a
specific question today about new york
governor cuomo's work on infrastructure
he also made clear it was right for
cuomo to step down reiterated his
support for women who come forward and
made clear he can't separate personal
behavior from other work
okay unless we're talking about tara
reid alleging that back in the 1990s joe
biden then a senator from delaware
actively
digitally raped her i mean that's her
actual allegation tara reid from the
1990s and we're supposed to pretend that
that never happened of course okay so
democrats felt that this was a time to
celebrate their own their own incredible
moral compass
so mehdi hassan from msnbc he led the
way and he he gave this whole
impassioned monologue about this just
shows that democrats are amazing at
policing their own
now
let's just be real about this
no they are 100
not
okay teddy kennedy was the lion of the
senate after leaving a woman to drown at
the bottom of a river
he ran for president again after doing
that i believe twice so no actually it
turns out you're not good at this
okay he was he was teddy kennedy was
doing waitress sandwiches with ever with
other esteemed members of the democratic
caucus in the senate okay and he was the
lion of the senate
you know what truly broke american
politics when it came to forcing
resignations i mean that was one of them
the other one would have been bill
clinton you'll remember that bill
clinton was impeached by the republican
house and the democrats stood with him
in fact you had democratic commentators
like nina berlay from time magazine
saying that she literally would have
performed oral sex on bill clinton to
keep abortion legal
so no i mean you guys broke it and now
you don't get to pretend that you're
putting it back together you're the
party of values excuse me but here is
mede hassan playing this game
republicans have been all over the
andrew cuomo story but have they looked
in the mirror recently
just take former missouri republican
governor eric greitens who resigned in
2018 amidst an ethics probe two criminal
charges reports he had an affair and
allegations of blackmail he's now
running again it's time for the senate
we have even seen this on the supreme
court clarence thomas was confirmed
despite anita hill's accusation of
sexual harassment so was brett kavanaugh
more recently after christine blasey
ford's accusation of sexual assault not
a single republican voted no on
cavanaugh's confirmation yeah i like
some of the examples he uses here he
says well how about eric greitens eric
greitens is going to run for senate
again you'll recall that in 2018 he was
the governor of missouri and he resigned
in the same way that andrew cuomo
resigned he also mentions in the same
breath as andrew cuomo about whom there
was a 168-page attorney general report
detailing all of the allegations
medical puts that in the same breath as
brett kavanaugh for which there was zero
actual evidence of contemporaneous
evidence
that any of the allegations about him
are true
and also clarence thomas which it was
rooted in one woman testifying that he
said a thing to her which was
unsubstantiated by any outside conduct
so that's exactly like andrew cuomo
according to many hassan
okay you no you guys do not get to do
this routine where you pretend that you
have the moral high ground but joy reed
is doing this right we have the joy reid
joy reed having the moral high ground
excuse me
joy reid still has a job on msnbc after
it came out that she had all sorts of
old blog posts that were openly
homophobic
and then she claimed like all good
journalists do that she had been hacked
that retroactively somebody went back
retroactively hacked her that lady still
has a show on msnbc
here she was saying we hold our own
accountable but the republicans don't
weird because ilhan omar and rashida
talib are still
well-established members of of the
congress of the united states elena
marshall on the foreign affairs
committee i noticed that steve king
ain't in congress anymore anyway here's
joy reid
cuomo's announcement uh and his exit
it actually highlights a glaring double
standard that we've got to discuss as
republicans who for four years excuse
donald trump try to join in on the
outrage and even claim a sort of victory
but honestly the truth is cuomo's exit
was entirely 100 percent the product of
democratic pressure because democrats
hold their own to a higher standard of
conduct meanwhile we still await the
resignation announcements from alleged
teen sex trafficker matt gates creepy
car guy madison cawthorne and jim jordan
okay when it comes to jim jordan the
allegations were that he was a member of
the coaching staff at like ohio state
when one of the upper level coaches was
sexually abusing some of the people who
were there there's no evidence he was
involved in a cover-up
like
and and again democrats are somehow the
people who we are supposed to believe
have a higher moral by the way who else
would have pressured andrew cuomo new
york democrats literally have a super
majority in the state senate
there are 63 seats in the state senate
in new jersey in new york rather and 43
of them are democrats who else would
have been republicans
they only have the capacity to bring
that kind of pressure
all of this is insane on his face okay
in just a second though i want to remind
you i just want to remind you that while
we all knew what andrew cuomo had done
to the olds in new york the entire
democratic party and media establishment
were celebrating him so don't give me
the we have high moral standards routine
it's just nonsense we'll get some more
of this in one second first no matter
how you are feeling about getting back
out there this summer there's no denying
it's an adjustment for everyone and when
the world can get too loud something i
love to do is create my own soundtrack i
pop in my raycon wireless earbuds
sometimes you need some upbeat music to
pump you up before you see people or to
stay calm with some guided meditation
let me tell you right now raycons are
the best way to listen they come with a
bunch of gel tips for your comfort
unlike some other brands they don't
stick out of your ears raycons have a
32-hour battery life so you can listen
to what you want when you want for a
really long time they start at half the
price of other premium audio brands but
they sound just as good and recon's come
with a 45 day happiness guarantee as
well so you really can't lose and you
try them you see if they work for you
and then if you don't like them you send
them back give them a try you're going
to want to keep them create your own
soundtrack with raycon right now my
listeners can get 15 off their raycon
order at byraycon.com
ben that is b u y r ay c 01.com slash
ben to say 15 on ray cons by raycon dot
com slash ben again that is by raycon
dot com slash ben and save 15
on your recon order today and get a
great pair of wireless earbuds to carry
you through a summer where you will be
back out there once more alrighty so
just a reminder the same people who are
proclaiming themselves the great moral
standard-bearers for the united states
spent the entire last year pretending
that andrew cuomo was a great governor
while he was killing all the old people
and covering it up we knew that he was
doing this by the way last summer i mean
there was open reporting from a wide
variety of right-wing sources about how
andrew cuomo had changed the reporting
standards in new york with regard to
nursing home deaths
but that was the exact same time the
media were too busy spawning over the
so-called love gov they literally called
him the love gov i mean the irony of
this is just beyond the pale they called
him the love god while he was grabbing
his subordinates ass that's unbelievable
okay here was the just a flashback media
montage of all of these people
performing the human centipede on andrew
cuomo
governor cuomo
out there day after day after day
everything trump isn't honest direct
brave real leadership of the kind the
president of the united states should
have provided governor cuomo
is clearly living in a totally different
reality
the actual one
than the president of the united states
governor cuomo has become a national
leader for a lot of people andrew cuomo
has become the leader of the democratic
party he is conveying incredible
strength you spoke to national guard
troops today in a stirring speech that
if i wasn't listening carefully i
thought you would sending soldiers off
to war means so inspirational you'll
recall that trevor noah calls himself a
homosexual on air
the one governor who's crushing it the
most right now is andrew cuomo yes
thanks to his handling his approval
rating has soared to a seven year high
and he's even becoming uh
something of a crush for many people
yeah people online are falling in love
with him
i'm not gonna lie those people include
me
my tinder profile now lists me as a
homosexual okay randy rainbow who of
course puts together these very
uncomfortable videos on tiktok and
youtube and twitter he had an entire
video
about how much he wanted to have sex
with andrew cuomo
kind and smart you touch my heart
your polo shirts are nice
[Music]
yeah man
spends a year doing that
doing that but now i'm supposed to
believe that um that you guys were it
was it was all morality all the time
he's just he was so good at this now my
favorite thing is that even amidst their
newfound moral fervor for getting rid of
andrew cuomo and their apparent hatred
uh like it is so funny how they bounce
around on the metoo stuff right if it's
joe biden we don't pay attention to the
metoo stuff it's donald trump we pay
super a lot of attention to the me too
stuff if it's andrew cuomo and there
were sort of these dark rumors last year
then we don't pay attention to it too
much uh and in fact we actually
mobilized some people who are involved
with time's up to attack his accusers if
however he becomes inconvenient then we
all remember that me too is still a
thing it's really fun how that works
well democrats are having trouble right
now determining whether they're actually
happy or sad that andrew cuomo is going
alec baldwin for example he says this is
a tragic day he put out a statement on
twitter quote regardless of what you
think of cuomo this is a tragic day
party politics in this country draw
ambitious but ultimately isolated even
socially maladjusted men and women who
given the current canceled culture will
likely have their shortcomings exposed
and magnified
tragic day so so tragic what will we do
without andrew cuomo chuck todd was
already talking comeback he ain't even
gone yet chuck
again give us like a minute here he like
he literally did not leave he resigned
he's still gonna be there for two weeks
presumably hoping that there will be
some miracle and he will reinstate
himself here is chuck todd suggesting a
comeback already
his career was either permanently over
or
almost permanently over and he chose the
path of almost permanently over right
the resignation gives him you know we
know the way our world works
um it's amazing the people we've seen
make political comebacks
you know you can't ever rule it out look
i expect
in my lifetime
andrew cuomo to probably run for office
again what that office is i don't know
but that's what this resignation tells
me today okay by the way i don't think
he's wrong i'm making fun of chuck
tabbed i don't think he's wrong i think
that's why andrew cuomo did it okay the
best take oh you can always count on
jennifer rubin for the best take
remember that time when jennifer rubin
was the in-house conservative at the
washington post remember how silly that
was
now she's just the crazy person at the
washington post one of many she tweeted
out the first new york woman governor
ever
now
see here's
here's the thing jennifer
you don't get to celebrate the first new
york woman governor
ever
if she assumed the office because a man
had to resign for grabbing ass
that is not how that works normally when
you talk about the first new york woman
governor or something that person has to
be elected
right like if you don't elect the person
we don't all get credit for that but
there is a certain irony by the way to
the fact that the person who is taking
over for andrew andrew cuomo's woman
named kathy hokel so uh she is an
ex-representative ex-congressional
representative kathy hoggle what's
hilarious about this is that the way
that she apparently rises in the world
through no fault of her own is not her
fault is that she just
comes in after a dude can't keep it in
his pants and takes over his office
that's like her actual career history
it's really really funny
and she became the first democrats to
represent new york's 26th congressional
district in decades how
well republican representative chris lee
was caught sending shirtless selfies to
a woman he met through craigslist
okay so she ended up winning that race
because her republican opponent was
sending shirtless pictures on craigslist
while running for office so she ended up
winning that race then of course she
ended up losing subsequent races
she rebounded from there into the
lieutenant governor's office and all she
had to do was wait for another dude who
couldn't keep it in his pants andrew
cuomo
so that's that's pretty i mean listen it
does say something about male
politicians that a pathway toward
victory is
just be second in line behind a male
politician like that's that's pretty
rich i i'm kind of admitting to to
enjoying that a little bit but here is
the bottom line in the end
what andrew cuomo's resignation says is
not much about the status of democratic
morality or about the status of the
metoo movement or anything like that it
says a lot about the politically
expedient way in which andrew cuomo was
capped off the side of the road right
they shut they shot sonny on the
causeway i mean that's that's all that
happened here
and we can pretend that there's an act
of moral virtue by democrats or that it
matters all that much but in the end it
really doesn't it doesn't he was
inconvenient so they got rid of him
okay in just one second we're going to
be getting to the latest on kovid
because the democrats are now in
full-scale
totalitarian centralization of power
mode we'll get to that in one second
first let's talk about a simple fact you
don't want to go to the auto parts store
because who does who who's like you know
what let's go hang out at the auto parts
store today you want to wait in line you
finally get to the front of the line you
go through a series of questions you
didn't know the answers to
and then finally when you get to the
front of that line then um they tell you
they have the part but not in stock and
they will have to order it enough charge
you or you could just skip all of that
and do all this from home anyway with
rockauto.com rocklotter.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts their family business serving auto
parts customers online for 20 years go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog's unique and
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rocklauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you why not use the interwebs to buy
auto parts the same way you use the
interwebs to buy everything else you can
competitively shop the parts over at
rockauto.com right now head on over
there remember to write your period how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you alrighty we'll get some
more news in just one moment first your
reminder you need to pick up a copy of
my book the authoritarian moment because
it's here okay so not just the book like
the authoritarian moment itself is here
the centralization of power in all the
institutions is here the willingness to
quash dissent from all the institutions
is here that includes the government and
non-governmental institutions that
govern your daily life the authoritarian
moment is about how all of our
institutions were taken over by the left
and more importantly how we coordinate
to fight back go check out the
authoritarian moment right now it's
available at amazon barnes noble or any
other major bookseller it's already sold
tens and tens and tens of thousands of
copies go get your copy right now leave
a five star review if you like what you
read also if there's any time to enter
to win a free trip to the daily wire
studio to meet candace owens and see her
live show that time is now if you sign
up now as a daily wire member with code
vip you get 25 off your new membership
and you will be automatically entered
for a chance to win a trip for two to
the daily wire studios to see candace
live not only will you be meeting
candace you'll be getting an inside look
at her studio and front row seats to
watch her take down leftist live and in
action on her talk show candace so get a
great deal on that new dailywire
membership at dailywire.com subscribe
with code vip and 25 off so you can
automatically be entered for a chance to
win that vip experience
not just that if you've ever wondered
what it's like to see candace owens
dismantle the delusional narrative
that's been mainstreamed in our society
i've got excellent news for you you can
now buy tickets to come to the daily
weather studio in nashville tennessee
and see her show live there is a catch
you have to be an all access member if
you are your lovely mug might even make
it on screen hurry tickets have sold out
for every single show seating is limited
go get your tickets right now they are
going fast if you live in that nashville
area or you've been planning to take a
trip there which i highly recommend now
is the time head on over to
dailywire.com tickets today to pick up
yours you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile democrats across the
land are calling for centralization of
power in the federal government
particularly joe biden came out
yesterday and said that he is now
investigating whether he has the federal
capacity to crack down on states and
essentially issue a national mass
mandate here is the president of the
united states trying to centralize the
power to tell texas and florida that
they are not allowed to tell schools
exactly how to operate and allow
students to go to school unmasked
powers to intervene in states like texas
and florida where they are banning mass
mandates i i i don't believe that i do
thus far we're checking that we but
there are on federal workforce i can
and uh
i think that
people should understand
seeing little kids i mean four five six
years old
in hospitals on ventilators
and some of them passing not many but
some of them passing
it's almost i mean it's it's just
well i should not characterize it beyond
that okay well you shouldn't
characterize it beyond that because it's
factually incorrect okay there are small
children who have died of covet the
number who had a non-severe who the
number who died who didn't have a severe
underlying condition before dying so far
as i'm aware is currently zero that's
according to johns hopkins university
statistics as phil kerpin points out
from american communications the
2009-2010 swine flu was five times
deadlier to kids than covet has been
but nobody talks about masking up kids
in schools the only reason we're even
talking about this right now is because
you have a bunch of freaked out adults
and they don't understand how to read
data and democrats are trying to scare
the living hell out of everybody so you
all get vaccinated listen i would love
for more people to get vaccinated i am
very pro-vaccine i've had the vaccine my
wife's had the vaccine my parents have
had the vaccine i've encouraged everyone
i know to get the vaccine but in the end
it's up to you you get to make the
decision as to whether you think the
vaccine is going to do you more harm
than good i can all i can do is provide
you the data and then allow you the
ability to make an independent decision
because this is still a free country but
joe biden is saying that he like when he
says he doesn't think he has the
authority to do the national mass
mandate stuff but he's going to check
into it
i am less than assured considering that
one week ago he said he did not have the
authority to issue an eviction
moratorium and then he went ahead and
issued an eviction moratorium so i don't
trust that his belief in the
constitutionality of what he's doing
matters one iota to joe biden
so what is this is real what this is
really about is pretending that
democrats have a solution when they very
clearly do not have a solution and again
the data that
that this is really dangerous for kids
does not exist there is no data
suggesting that this is a wildly
dangerous virus for children okay the
nih director says this here's the ni the
current this isn't me is francis collins
the current nih director saying there is
no rigorous data showing that the delta
variant is more dangerous to kids than
the alpha variant and the alpha variant
is responsible for the deaths of under
400 children in the united states out of
a sub-population of 75 plus million here
is nih director francis collins
is the delta variant more serious for
children
you know we don't have rigorous data to
show for sure that they are but i
certainly am hearing from pediatricians
that they're concerned that this time
the kids who are in the hospital are
both more numerous and more seriously
ill we'll have to get better comparisons
to be sure of that
so no you don't have data
your anecdotal evidence is virtually
meaningless
as the delta variance is more contagious
that means more people are going to get
it if more people get it more people are
going to become hospitalized from it but
that does not mean that it is more
dangerous on a raw one-to-one level it
just means more people are getting it
okay what this is really about is the
false suggestion that democrats have the
solution and this is a point of high
irritation to me it really is israel is
seeing a major spike right now israel
went
crazy with the vaccinations they went
crazy with the lockdowns they are still
seeing record spikes right now in israel
california is seeing a major spike right
now in cases
i'm vacationing in hawaii right now and
let me tell you hawaii has seen a spike
in cases and hawaii has been locked down
hawaii is a mass mandate state
i'm looking at the hawaii case right
right now and right now hawaii has been
experiencing a massive spike
okay as of august 9th their five day
their seven day rolling average is 514
cases
just about a month ago it was 40 cases a
day
so what happened is that governor ron
desantis fault in florida or does it
turn out that this thing is really
contagious a lot of people are getting
it
and that's pretty much it but again
democrats have to suggest that they have
the solution if only you would listen to
them so here's gensake ripping around
desantis of course
if you're not interested in following
the public health guidelines to protect
the lives of people in your state to
give parents
some comfort as they're sending their
kids to school schools are opening in
florida this week i know in many parts
of florida then get out of the way and
let public officials let local officials
do their job to keep students safe this
is serious and we're talking about
people's lives and we know based on
public health guidelines that even
though kids under a certain age are not
yet eligible uh masks can have a huge
impact
okay
no that there's no evidence that masking
in schools has a huge impact
there really isn't okay i'll give you an
example so today there's an article in
the new york times and if you read the
headline
you would assume that what sake is
saying is true right that there's actual
evidence here is what the essay says we
studied 1 million students this is what
we learned about masking this is by dr
kenesia zimmerman and dr danny benjamin
one is an associate professor of
pediatrics at duke the other is a
pediatric infectious disease specialist
at duke
here's what they say they say for more
than a year we've worked with north
carolina school districts and charter
schools studying the rate of new coveted
cases the efficacy of mitigation
measures such as masking and the
increased risks of participating in
school-sponsored sports we have learned
a few things for certain although
vaccination is the best way to prevent
copenhagen universal masking is a close
second and with masking in place
in-school learning is safe and more
effective than remote instruction
regardless of community rates of
infection
okay then they actually get to the data
and the data don't show any of that
they say vaccination is the strongest
method for preventing the ill effects of
covered but students under 12 are
ineligible for the vaccines masking then
is one of the best most readily
available methods to protect them from
disease with universal masking being one
of the most effective and efficient
strategies for preventing stars covet ii
transmission in schools
so how do they know this
according to these scientists in july
2020 we and our colleagues developed the
abc science collaborative to pair
scientists with school and community
leaders to make sure that school leaders
had the most up-to-date school
scientific information pertaining to
cover 19 and k-12 schools
in conjunction with north carolina our
collaborative collected data from more
than one million students and staff
members in the state's schools from
march to june of 2021.
during that time more than 7 thousand
children and adults acquired the
coronavirus and attended school while
infectious because of close contact with
those cases more than 40 000 people
required quarantine through contact
tracing and testing however we found
only 363 additional children and adults
acquired the coronavirus we believe that
this low rate of transmission occurred
because of the mask on mask school
environment both the infected person and
the close contact wore masks
but here's the key okay this is buried
way down in the article because north
carolina had a mask mandate for all k
through 12 schools we could not compare
masked schools to unmasked schools
let me repeat that the entire article is
about how masking is deeply effective
quote because north carolina had a mass
mandate for all k-12 schools we could
not compare mass schools to unmasked
schools
that's the only thing we care about
if you have no comp what the hell are
you talking about how am i supposed to
know whether the masking was effective
or not when i don't know whether an
unmasked school would have done worse
you literally have no comp
so what did they do
instead they just pulled a bunch of like
outlying
cases from israel for example they say
by contrast one school in israel without
a mass mandate or proper social
distancing protocols reported an
outbreak of coven 19 involving 153
students and 25 staff members
so you so you had no comp so you just
picked an outlier and used that as your
comp
okay so there's a really interesting
twitter thread
from a a columnist science columnist for
wired in the new york times and the
atlantic name david zweig he said i
corresponded with the authors of the
duke study behind this opinion piece
weeks ago
a top-line finding of the duke abc
science collaborative report and what
they claim here is that masks in schools
help lower transmission except all their
schools were under a mass mandate i
asked the authors how they could make a
claim on mass when there was no control
in order to claim an effect you have to
compare one group with an intervention
to a second group without the
intervention which they didn't do
instead
they talked about this israeli school
but one you cannot use another study as
evidence for a claimed finding in your
study you didn't do the study two the
israeli study was of grades at seven
through twelve windows were closed all
schools were exempt from masks
all in israel if anything the fact that
there was only one outbreak suggests the
lack of effectiveness of masks
this is absurd
the schools in florida and more so
throughout many parts of europe did not
and do not have mass mandates for kids
with varying age cutoffs there is no
correlated explosion of cases
originating in those schools
when when this particular columnist for
wired and the new york times doesn't
sound like a conservative columnist when
this person emailed the people who wrote
for the new york times and mentioned
these points about the israeli study
they cut off all communications
but but based on the scampi based on the
skimpy data we're supposed to believe
that it's time to mask up all students
and if you don't this is because you're
evil like rhonda sanchez is evil
see dr anthony fauci sums it up here is
dr fauci the greatest of all doctors
outside of joe biden saying that the
florida surge was quote unquote entirely
preventable
okay here we go scientifically they're
going to take us continuing to escalate
up and the people of florida are going
to suffer unnecessarily there will be
unnecessary hospitalization
and tragically unnecessary
deaths that's exactly what is going to
happen it is
entirely predictable on the one hand
and entirely preventable on the other
hand if what he's talking about there is
vaccines
agree if what he is talking about there
is the evils of florida for not doing
mask mandates which again do not
correlate with high death rates
or low death rates there's no
correlation
then he doesn't know what he's talking
about by the way it is worth noting that
it appears that florida has already hit
its peak
okay so in two weeks nobody's gonna be
talking about florida anymore
the covet date
the the covet count by date for florida
friday twenty one thousand five hundred
saturday nineteen thousand five hundred
sunday fifteen thousand three hundred
and three hundred nineteen
so they may already have hit their peak
scott gottlieb from the fda says the
same thing by the way so it'll be a
trailing peak in hospitalizations and
deaths
okay but again the key comes down to
here's anthony fauci i love this here's
dr fauci saying you know what here's the
thing he gets to decide for you
what sort of freedoms you get to enjoy
you would wish that people would see why
it's so important to get vaccinated but
you're not going to get mandates
centrally from the federal government
but when you're talking about local
mandates mandates for schools for
teachers for universities for colleges
i'm sorry i i mean i know people must
like to have their individual freedom
and not be told to do something but i
think we're in such a serious situation
now that under certain circumstances
mandates should be done okay that
sentence right there i know people must
like to have their individual freedom
but
there shouldn't be a butt at the end of
that sentence
i know people like to have their
individual freedom
is the end of the sentence there's a
period at the end of that sentence
people still have a right to their
individual freedom and they yes they
bear the consequences
again i'm not hearing from a lot of
people who believe that they don't have
to get the vaccine
and also everybody else has to mask up
around them because they have to be kept
in a bubble
individual rights still matter in this
country that i know they don't seem to
matter for an awful lot of democrats
these days
but they still matter and if democrats
keep pursuing these mass mandates and
lockdowns and vaccine mandates i don't
think the american people are going to
respond well to this nor do i think that
they should respond well to it frankly i
think they should be resisting a lot of
this stuff
because it is not rooted in reason and
is not rooted in any sort of real moral
sensibility that allows for the
individuality of human choice making
that you don't like personally
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow
with much much more in the meantime go
check out the michael knowles show that
is available right now i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode new york governor andrew
cuomo resigns chicago police turn their
backs on the mayor and the u.s has a
record 10.1 million job openings join us
and get the facts first on the news you
need to know with our show morning wire